a big portion of like 406 where I'm not
in it and it was a good day of directing
Alana which was such a pleasure cuz not
having directed you you get the full
experience when you're not in it when
you're directing and you're in it you're
like constantly like putting this hat
any like these hats and you're like
putting them on top of each other for me
it's about setting everything up and
planning and so I can be in the scene as
an actor as much as possible for tenure
you are watching the your other actors
in the scene as the director it was fun
but it was like a lot you're gonna be a
hit here Thanks that Marco is a ninety
which it's so exciting working with
these women I'm Jane Curtin and I'm
playing Margo like insane she's an
absolute joy so funny I studied her as a
kid and a comedy nerd she kept throwing
in like surprising improv she's amazing
my mom is an artist and Shane's
character Margo her table is all my
mom's actual artwork so my mom really
liked that there's a feeling on the set
you feel free you feel safe so it's a
pleasure being here
Margo can you watch my stuff first thing
I got money to spend money is a line
control technique that quantifies the
progress of the patriarchy
yeah watches
[Music]